While kids absolutely adore Marvel movies,
there's a lot about this franchise that only
grown-ups will appreciate.
From tacky outfits and glossed-over casualties
to an incessant barrage of quick-witted innuendos,
here are some things in the MCU that only
adults will notice.
Between the mythological gods, radioactive
monsters, and talking racoons, it's pretty
obvious that no one is going into a Marvel
movie looking for a dose of realism.
When it comes to space travel, though, believability
gets stretched pretty far, even by the goofiest
sci-fi standards.
At this point, a fair number of humans have
been shown making trips through space.
Sometimes this has very real consequences,
like when Tony Stark nearly died from a lack
of oxygen, or when Peter Parker had to be
saved before he was yanked out of the atmosphere
by the Black Order's spaceship.
At other times, though, any of the problems
with being in space or on an alien planet
are completely ignored.
When our very human heroes get to Thanos's
home world of Titan in Avengers: Infinity
War, they're able to breathe just fine on
an alien planet.
The same goes for Vormir when Hawkeye and
Black Widow head over there in Endgame to
find everything hunky-dory, physiologically
speaking.
The movies spend a lot of time on the pseudo-science
that explains all of the strange phenomena
throughout the MCU, but space travel seems
to operate entirely on whatever seems convenient
for the plot.
Kids might not notice, but if you're old enough
to have taken a science class, or even read
the original Infinity Gauntlet comics, where
suffocating in the vacuum of space is a pretty
big concern during these superhero battles,
it's an easy detail to get hung up on.
In most of their films, the Marvel masterminds
have managed to keep a core of something believable
within the context of their very unbelievable
stories.
Captain America: Civil War centers on a very
realistic showdown built around relatable
ideas of loyalty and betrayal, even if it
also involves flying androids, robotic power
armor, and teenagers with spider-strength.
In spite of it all, the serious tone of the
film draws the audience past all that and
into that emotional core.
That doesn't change the fact that many of
the superheroic struggles taking place throughout
the MCU are ridiculously lopsided, however.
Take the fight with Thanos on Titan.
Endgame shows us that he's a villain that
can hold his own against super-powerful characters
like Captain Marvel, even without the Infinity
Gauntlet, but in Infinity War, the Mad Titan
spends several minutes struggling against
characters like Drax and Star-Lord.
Sure, Drax is strong, but he's not strong
enough to destroy an entire fleet of spaceships
with his bare hands, and Peter Quill is really
just a guy with laser guns and a comprehensive
knowledge of classic rock.
They're not exactly the biggest threats.
It's not just that fight scene, either.
You can see the wildly imbalanced super-powers
on display just by looking at the Avengers.
On the one hand, you have characters like
Black Widow and Hawkeye, who are incredibly
skilled and deadly by regular human standards.
On the other hand, you have the Hulk, who
can punch out space monsters the size of a
battleship, and Thor, the literal god of Thunder.
Kids like to see all of their favorite standing
shoulder-to-shoulder, but as adults, we have
to ask: is Clint Barton really contributing
a whole lot to the fight?
It doesn't matter if you're witnessing the
epic climax of the film, or even a fight between
the heroes themselves, superheroic battles
are almost always the focus of these movies.
The consequences of those battles, however,
are all over the map.
Sometimes the lasting effects of a major encounter
play an important part of the story, like
the destruction of Sokovia in Avengers: Age
of Ultron.
That one is treated as a massive tragedy with
huge ramifications for the rest of the universe.
For every scene like this, however, there
are a dozen that never really bring up all
the collateral damage that comes along with
trashing armies of alien drones or swinging
around magic hammers.
The Battle of New York in Avengers, for instance,
is shown to be so devastating that the World
Security Council is willing to nuke Manhattan,
which has to indicate a ridiculous number
of casualties.
And yet, once the credits roll, it's never
brought up again.
The same goes for the end of Captain America:
The Winter Soldier, where S.H.I.E.L.D.
Helicarriers are dropping out of the sky over
Washington, DC and into the Potomac river.
These are incredibly destructive events in
highly populated areas, and as adults, that's
the kind of thing we tend to think about once
we're out of the theater.
Here's a fun fact: if you're under the age
of, say, 18, then you've never really experienced
a pop cultural landscape that didn't feature
the MCU.
The characters, on the other hand, seem pretty
well-acquainted with the movies that hit theaters
long before Tony Stark built himself a suit
of super-armor in a cave…even the younger
ones.
"Hey guys!
You ever see that really old movie…Empire
Strikes Back?"
"Jesus, Tony, how old is this guy?!"
"I don't know, I didn't carbon date him.
He's on the young side."
The superheroes of the Marvel Universe are
always throwing out references to classic
movies, from Peter Parker's love of the Star
Wars trilogy to Tony Stark referring to Thor
as "Point Break."
We've even seen Captain Marvel crashing down
to Earth in a Blockbuster Video, which, for
those youngsters among you, was sort of like
a Netflix that you had to physically drive
to, and you could only watch the movie you
wanted if you got there before everyone else
got off work.
That's exactly the kind of reference that
today's kids just aren't going to understand.
We've come a long way from the X-Men films
of the early 2000s, where the characters swapped
out their familiar, brightly colored comic
book costumes for allegedly "functional" black
leather outfits.
"You actually go outside in these things?"
"What would you prefer?
Yellow spandex?"
These days, we've all gotten used to seeing
superheroes showing up on screen looking just
like their source material, but that doesn't
change the fact that their outfits are often
straight-up ridiculous.
That doesn't mean they look bad, though.
Without those colorful suits, the MCU would
wind up being a pretty drab place.
It's just that we never quite get why nobody
chooses to dress in something a little more
practical.
Just look at Steve Rogers.
His original costume is meant to be, well,
a costume.
It's specifically made for his on-stage appearances
selling war bonds.
When he goes into action, however, he dresses
more like a soldier…for about five minutes.
He's then given a slightly more functional
version of his stage costume, and for some
reason sticks with it when he wakes up in
the 21st century, too.
Even when he goes underground after the events
of Civil War, he keeps the same suit and just
takes off all the white parts to go with a
cool new beard.
For a kid, all that makes sense: Cap looks
like that because that's just what Captain
America looks like.
For the cynical, critical adult eyes, though,
we have to wonder why he doesn't just dress
in a more tactical outfit.
And, for that matter, why Tony Stark doesn't
just build everyone on the team a suit of
armor, especially the ones who are very vulnerable
to getting shot.
"You can't have it."
Captain America: Civil War is a great movie.
It has one of the franchise's most memorable
battles, introduces not one, but two brand-new
major characters to the MCU, picks up on plot
threads from Age of Ultron, and ties together
the entire Marvel Cinematic Universe while
still focusing on its title character and
how far he's willing to go to help his friends.
It also seems on the surface like it's a perfect
movie for kids to get excited about.
After all, Spider-Man has always been a favorite
for younger fans, and what kid wouldn't be
excited to see Ant-Man growing up to giant
size during that unforgettable airport battle
in Germany?
The rest of the movie, on the other hand,
might not be ideal for that particular audience.
In addition to being built around the fact
that Captain America's best friend just straight-up
murdered Iron Man's mom and dad, most of the
plot of Civil War is a debate about government
oversight.
As exciting as it is to see Captain America
bicep-curling a helicopter, having two characters
argue over whether they should submit to authority
or remain independent in order to follow their
own moral compass and pursue a more proactive,
interventionist policy is…well, it's not
exactly what the elementary school set is
excited about.
And that's before you get to the part where
the main villain is doing everything simply
because he craves death.
Yikes.
Fortunately, anyone who was a little too young
for all that probably just remembers how cool
it was when Ant-Man rode on Hawkeye's arrow.
It's just like the comics!
It's not unusual for a movie that appeals
to kids to throw in some jokes for the grown-ups
in the audience, and with the kind of cross-generational
appeal that has led to record-breaking box
office totals, the MCU movies are no exception.
The thing is, in these movies, all those "adult"
jokes are, well, really adult, especially
when they're coming from Tony Stark and Peter
Quill.
Iron Man always has a sarcastic retort ready
for any situation, like when he asked Black
Widow and Hulk if they were playing "hide
the zucchini," or when he took a swipe at
Hawkeye for having a little difficulty lifting
up Mjolnir.
"We won't hold it against you if you can't
get it up."
Star-Lord, on the other hand, makes Tony look
like he could be teaching Sunday School.
In a movie that features a talking raccoon,
you know, for the kids…
"Oh.
Yeah."
...the Guardians' leader mentions that his
starship would look a lot like a Jackson Pollack
painting underneath a blacklight.
If you're an adult, you already get it.
And that's just the tip of the innuendo iceberg.
Fortunately, these are exactly the kind of
jokes that are going to go right over the
kids' heads.
Unless, of course, they have reflexes like
Drax.
"Nothing goes over my head.
My reflexes are too fast, I would catch it."
If the past ten years have proven anything,
it's that kids love Iron Man.
There are plenty of reasons why, too.
He's a modern-day knight in literal shining
armor, with a seemingly endless personal fortune
and enough smarts to literally invent a new
element in his basement.
He's the cool exec with a heart of steel,
and hey, Spider-Man likes him, too, so all
the other kids should too, right?
Not exactly.
"You missed me?
I missed you too.
Blow something up?
I already did that."
Tony Stark's entire character arc over the
course of ten years of movies is built around
some very adult-oriented themes, many of which
might be missed by younger viewers who are
busy focusing on the glitz and glamor of the
Iron Man armor.
The man started as a playboy who was constantly
womanizing and drinking without a care in
the world.
He treated people like garbage and didn't
blink twice at the moral struggle of living
off of a fortune built on dealing weapons.
Even after he made his change and started
to reforge his personality into one of the
greatest superheroes in the entire MCU, his
story remained just as adult in nature.
In Age of Ultron, he dealt with a world that
was suddenly a whole lot bigger than he thought
by making huge mistakes, and Iron Man 3 is
a movie entirely about post-traumatic stress
disorder.
Even in his final moments, his inner struggles
continued until he accepted that he'd have
to sacrifice his own life, and any chance
of seeing his daughter grow up, to save everyone
else.
Without a doubt, the quantity of high-minded,
adult level material in the Stark storyline
is overwhelming.
But hey!
That armor's pretty cool, right?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.